Voici David Lopez qui vient de La Nievre et qui a fait une vidéo en 2012 parce qu'il était très très remonté
contre Joe Lopez, un autre Lopez de Clermond-Ferrand
On vient d'apprendre des nouvelles insultes
dont on a jamais entendu parler.
Apprends des insultes avec David Lopez !
Bonjour, ce qui termine par "mort" devient une insulte !
calotte de ses morts
sang de ses morts
bâtard de ses mort
Piège !
trompette de la mort
C'est un champignon...!
À la semaine prochaine !
C'était "Apprends des insultes avec David Lopez" !
Alors David a voulu faire participer sa femme à cette vidéo,
c'est une sorte de... de "collaboration artistique" voilà, main dans la main
ils font ça ensemble et c'est très beau.
David, David !
Tu peux pas dire "Ferme ta gueule" et "Parle", euh... dans la même phrase.
Dis-leur !
Le sang de...
Ferme ta gueule ! Dis-leur !
Ferme ta gueule !
Vas-y dis-leur, je dis plus rien...tu vois...
– Le sang de...
– Ferme ta gueule !
Raaaah David...!
C'est de relents, je... me contrôle pas.
A un moment, il a tenté une insulte,
euh, j'me suis mis à la place de sa femme
et ça m'a pas fait plaisir...
Ben non, non non non.
On est en 2015, toujours pas de, de... de fin du monde euh, je crois.
Je crois hein, faudra qu'on me... confirme ça quand même.
Et maintenant, la réponse de Joe ! Et tout d'un coup,
ça monte d'un cran !
On remarquera le souci de mise en scène
pour IMPRESSIONNER hein, torse nu avec d'autre mecs musclés...!
Alors ça ne marque que si t'as le BON entourage.
Moi par exemple, ça ne... ça ne marche pas.
Bon y a faire la vidéo ! Parc'que y a une tapette là, qui dit que...
Eh vous m'aviez dit qu'vous faisiez de  la muscu' là, les mecs !
Voilà ! ÇA c'est du muscle !
– T'as vu ? Ça c'est du muscle !
– Regarde !
Alors à c'moment-là, euh...J'avoue, j'avoue avoir un p'tit peu peur euh
pour ma vie, en faisant cette vidéo.
Je... aimerais bien vivre euh... encore un peu le... les Lopez. Hein ? Si vous plaît.
Bon, je veux bien apprendre des nouvelles insultes, ok.
Par contre, apprendre une toute nouvelle langue,
NON !
Alors là, je... non. Non, je ne comprends pas, hein.
Pourtant j'ai mis les sous-titres automatiques sur YouTube mais ça ne marche pas.
Bon, les mecs, petit conseil de YouTubeur :
quand tu fais une vidéo,
tu te retiens de te gratter les couilles...
Même, même si ça gratte fort, même si ça... tu... Non.
Là, il faut mettre, euh, un truc ! Du TALC, je sais pas !
Visiblement, ça... ça démange !
Même moi j'ai envie de gratter le... je sais pas pourquoi !
Et Djo termine la vidéo sur un trait de modestie :
Et forcément, surprise pour absolument personne,
réponse de David !
David, ça c'est normal !
Alors j'dois m'faire démonter la gueule, 100 kilomètres aller, 100 kilomètres retour...
Je vais peut-être pas accepter.
À voir quand même c'que j'fais demain....?
Moi j'adore David parc'que... dans ses messages, c'est vraiment, euh... "chanteur de metal", quoi.
Bon David a un p'tit peu menti hein, un tout p'tit mensonge,
voilà, il a dit qu'il est tout seul... Bon, il a fait une autre vidéo après ça.
Bon David tu prends des mecs chauds "patate", les mecs i'sont bouillants, avec les fusils,
i'sont comme ça, c'est super...!
POURQUOI ?
Tu prends à parti le seul mec,
qu'on a l'impression qu'il s'demande c'qu'il fout ici !
J'avais du mal à les départager
qui je préférais entre David et Djo...?
Et c'est vrai
que Djo a un argument plutôt pas mal !
♪ la famille lopez j'vais la dédicacer ♪
♪ elle détient l'reccord d'toutes les machoires cassées ♪
Henock Cortes !
Un rappeur qui est pote avec les Lopez du 63.
Et la légende raconte qu'il roule en V12 et qu'il a l'humour de Jamel Debbouze.
♪ j'roule en V12, j'ai l'humour à Jamel Debbouze ♪
♪ j'trinque avec mes couz'...
NON, non non non !
Quand tu fais un clip musical, tu ne te filmes pas devant un tag qui a une faute à chaque mot !
Ils sont 12 000 dans le clip, y a personne qui s'est dit :
"Y'a une faute à chaque mot. Chaque mot, y'a une faute, c'est pas normal."
Alors petit conseil pour Henock : euh, quand tu fais un clip,
que tu prennes des mecs musclés, bon ça c'est pas mal,
mais un acrobate dangereux, euh non.
En plus t'es obligé de l'esquiver pendant qu'tu rappes,
'fin le mec il est infernal, quoi !
Et en même temps, tout l'monde est super impressionné,
moi j'suis super impressionné attends, il a des super bons réflexes Henock, il...
T'esquives tout, comme ça ?
Voilà, c'est tout pour le clash des Lopez !
Alors oui, il y a une famille Lopez qui n'a RIEN à voir
avec le clash ; ils ont rien à voir, si ce n'est le nom,
mais ils interviennent quand même.
Et je suis particulièrement fan des mecs derrière,
très passifs, hein ils ne bougent pas, rien...
Sauf, bien sûr, quand ils entendent LE mot clé, hein,
dès qu'ils entendent "castagnette"...!
J'ai un peu d'peine hein, pour le... pour le mec à droite,
qui VEUT participer, mais il... on lui... laisse pas sa chance, hein c'est...
Et le mec à gauche, lui c'est... c'est tout ou rien, hein
c'est une sorte d'1, 2, 3, Soleil, c'est "ne bouge pas",
et d'un coup C'EST PARTI !
Voilà, c'est tout pour le clash des Lopez !
Alors bien sûr c'est de l'humour, hein, les Lopez, les euh...
laissez... laissez-moi en vie, hein euh...
Je... Je veux vivre.
N'HÉSITEZ PAS à vous abonner à ma chaîne, et comme disait le Lopez du 36 :
Je raccroche.
“Peux-tu faire une imitation de Squeezie et Norman...?”
“FAUX !”
“Pff ! C'est à croire que toutes les filles s'sont mises d'accord !”
“Attends mais Norman t'es trop moche !
– Ouais, t'as trop raison, super...!”